I'd like to introduce Adrienne more
who's vice president of policy for the
reason foundation good morning thank you
all for coming so yes I'm vice president
at the reason foundation those of you
not familiar with the reason foundation
it's a nonprofit organization 40 years
old where we have offices in LA and
Washington DC we published reason
magazine the the magazine of free minds
and free markets and my division the the
policy division focuses on working with
state local and sometimes federal
government officials on implementing
policy changes we specialize in a lot of
different research areas Environmental
Policy transportation policy government
finance education reform and so forth in
transportation I myself am a
transportation economist though I've
worked in lots of other areas since I've
been at reason and transportation is a
particular passion we've worked on
transportation since 1970 and we've
specialized in the development of
different forms of road pricing
innovations in delivering transportation
infrastructure of various types around
the world and five years ago this fellow
named Bob Galvin called me out of the
blue and said can I meet with you I want
to talk about transportation and so I'm
googling up Galvan and I'm like oh yeah
that's right he's the former CEO of
Motorola and he's here in Chicago so I
came out we met and I hadn't really he
just said I want to talk about
transportation so it was really sort of
but you know he's Bob Galvin so
certainly I'm willing to have the
conversation we sit down and he starts
telling me about his perspective as head
of Motorola building factories all over
the world all over the United States
trying to run a large company and
you know what I've come to realize is
that congestion is going to gut our
economy that our production of our
economy of goods and services takes
place primarily in our metropolitan
areas and our metropolitan areas are
being strangled by congestion it's like
hardening of the arteries it's like too
much cholesterol just eventually it's
going to clog things up until they stop
working and I can already see these
costs are far beyond what any of our
conventional rather poor measures of the
economic cost of congestion and he
proceeded to list all these different
ways in which congestion is affecting
the economy that is not captured in any
of the measures that transportation
economists use and he said this this we
can't have this it's got to be solved
you know can we work together to come up
with solutions to major metropolitan
area congestion and so we started
working together those of you who picked
up a copy of the book mobility first out
there if you want to pick one if you
didn't get one and you want one on the
way out please grab one that's sort of
sam who's you're gonna hear from in a
few minutes and i wrote that and it sort
of encompasses everything we we came up
with working with bob over the years on
on addressing the problem of congestion
and one of the things we decided to do
to make it a little more tangible was go
to a bunch of different cities around
the nation and go through the modeling
process the planning process and look at
what could be done in different cities
to actually reduce congestion because as
you're probably familiar the current
long-range transportation plan in all
american metropolitan areas including
chicago is to spend many billions of
dollars over the next 25 years and for
congestion to get worse I think if the
school system came and said you know
what our 25-year plan is to spend
billions of dollars educating children
of 25 years and test scores are going to
go down sorry that's just the way it is
so we're going to spend billions of
dollars in congestion is going to be
stable and I don't think anybody thinks
congest
is good in Chicago right now so as in
all the other metropolitan area is what
we're trying to do is is is figure out
are there ways unconstrained the
planning process is is constrained by a
lot of federal rules it in some ways
it's it's you know trying to marry
federal money state money constraints
bring all of the different parties
together you have wind up with a lot of
of ladles in the pot besides solving
congestion and so our plan focuses much
more specifically on addressing
congestion which is a key measure of the
success of the transportation system for
a lot of users and our approach to that
is too I'm oversimplifying here but to
try to identify projects that would
produce a lot of mobility benefits
relative to the costs and allow people
to move within the region 25 years from
now more freely than they otherwise
would be able to do and ideally to have
the that system be largely self-funded
rather than having to be funded out of
the current transportation funds which
anybody who follows transportation knows
aren't really adequate for doing what
the current goals are so we have a
problem with inadequate resources for
transportation we don't want to add to
that problem with this project so going
back to Bob Galvan's vision you know how
do we how do we practically and
concretely develop ideas that if
implemented would reduce congestion in
the region and provide people with more
choices that they actually want to take
advantage of rather than trying to
change their behavior trying to trying
to convince people to do things
differently from what they want to do
but instead build a system that would
serve what they want to do so the that's
culminated here in the Chicago plan
we've done plans in Atlanta Miami Lee
County Florida we have plans coming out
over the next couple years in Denver Los
Angeles Phoenix and Northern Virginia
DC so among all of those I think we're
going to see how these ideas actually
play out in a lot of different
metropolitan area settings so to talk a
little bit more detail about what we're
proposing here in Chicago I want to
introduce Sam's daily he's the lead
author of the report my colleague he's
the director at the Deveaux more center
at Florida State University he divides
his time between there and Dayton Ohio
he's a senior fellow at Reason
Foundation has worked with reason for
many many years on land use planning
issues as well as transportation
planning and implementation and he's had
quite the journey working with our
partners on developing this plan for
Chicago that he's now going to explain
to you thanks Sam Thank You Adrienne and
thank you to the union league club of
chicago for allowing us to for hosting
this forum and also and should emphasize
it is going to be a forum so what I'm my
plan to do here is really spend the next
15 or 20 minutes talking a little bit
more about the plan the perspective give
you a provide a little bit of an
overview in terms of how we went about
developing the plan and what some of the
results were but immediately following
me there will be comments from Peters
cosis vice president of the Metropolitan
Planning Council in Richard Porter who
is a vice president at the Federal
Reserve Board of Chicago and we're
hoping John gates will be able to make
it as well who's chairman of the RTA so
and I think that's actually the way
we've structured this forum is actually
important for understanding the way we
sort of look at this study and that we
recognize that what we're going to
propose while it's we believe it's
actually quite bold for what's been
proposed in the past we believe it's
important for creating a discussion and
being part of the public debate about
infrastructure in transportation the
Chicago area and we think we're putting
some things on the table that are
different and also hopefully are
complementary to some things that are
already happening in Chicago but we
think we're taking it to the next level
but the purpose of the forum is to
actually add to that conversation to
that
and I think you'll find certainly with
Peters comments and others that there
are different perspectives that are
gonna be brought into this and the
question we will have is what we're
going to be trying to propose is how
does what we're talking about fit into
the broader scheme of what we're trying
to accomplish in Chicago and again to
reiterate what Adrian what mentioned
what we're really trying to do is
thinking about a way to tame congestion
because we believe that congestion and
particularly its rising congestion if
we're talking about growth over a period
of 20 or 30 years or actually or longer
this is something that is economically
debilitating and so the question is what
can we do about it now part of what we
were trying to do at Reason Foundation
is also ask ourselves where is our
value-added where can we contribute to
the debate in other words given our
expertise our background what we have
been investing in for over 30 years what
is what perspective can we bring into
this that others might and to be honest
we've been in the forefront of road
pricing p3s and other in regional
approaches to transportation so it also
made sense for us to make this a
cornerstone of our approach looking at
congestion in Chicago so let me just
move quickly through some background a
little bit give you to help frame this
and then move into some of the and also
provide a little bit of background on
the way we did the modeling how we did
it and then talk about the results first
of all as many people in this room are
probably familiar with congestion is
already in the billions of dollars in
terms of the costs imposed on the
Chicago economy and is expected to
increase at least based on the forecast
that we've been looking that we've been
examining as well as studies done not
just by reason foundation but others as
well and so in on some metrics she got a
congestion in Chicago on certain parts
of the system are severe is even in Los
Angeles and we've detailed some of this
smell all these data that we're
providing in this form are actually
detailed on the longer study so that's
something to which is available on the
web as well one of the things that we
found interesting though is when we were
looking at the way traffic is
distributed within the region is that
the expressways are
actually an important source of a lot of
these congestion in Chicago at
particularly the Chicago area and one of
the things that strike out or instruct
me for example was that while
expressways account for nineteen percent
of the lane miles they actually count
for thirty-six percent of the travel
delay and so we really thought early on
in the study and we've been coming to
Chicago 40 2007 I think is a 2006 we
decided to early on if we were going to
really look for a place where we could
make an impact the expressways and
trying to think about that the network
impacts and how that relates to the
region is going to be a crucial part of
that another aspect of this which we
believe and is that new capacity has to
be part of the solution we recognize
it's not gonna be the entire solution
but it needs to be an important part of
the solution and we believe based on not
only our studies of Chicago and
elsewhere and as an urban economists
looking at transportation over decades
that new capacity is really necessary
part of any plan moving forward so the
question becomes what kind of capacity
is that how much is it and how do you
actually finance it those become
important I and I honestly believe that
you're not going to be able to address
congestion or make serious inroads into
it unless you're looking at serious
expansions and capacity particularly if
you're growing meaning you're adding
people you're adding jobs all of that
require requires a major investment in
new infrastructure and we do believe
that in Chicago and we talk about this
in more detail in the study I can't get
into it here there's certainly a lot
that can be done to improve the
efficiency of the existing system but we
also believe that a crucial part of this
is going to be adding to the existing
system with new capacity what our
primary focus were one again it's Adrian
mentioned some of this soil I'll be very
brief about it we're looking for
absolute reductions in travel time and
other words are actually reducing
congestion so people get from point A to
point B faster we're looking at regional
capacity improvements and we were very
intent on identifying specific projects
in other words we didn't want this to be
abstract adding X number of Lane miles
for example we wanted to actually get
down to the nitty-gritty what kinds of
projects and what parts of the region
seemed to make sense we are also really
fo
it's on financing because proposing a
project without a way to pay for it
really is not going to do much good for
for many people so the other question
for us and reason again has been in the
forefront of road pricing for decades at
this point we're really focused on
whether user fees could actually
underwrite the cost of this and when we
started out we weren't sure if it was
going to be one hundred percent or fifty
percent the bottom line is we had to
analyze these projects in the context of
Chicago's actual transportation needs
and projected at economic growth before
we could figure that out we also as I
mentioned talk we do talk about I
improving the operations of the system
and we also looked at regional transit
investments and I'll talk about that in
a little bit and but we may actually but
that's also something that we didn't
ignore doing this process so what did we
do well first of all what we did is we
built on rabbit we don't well let me
back up a little bit when Reason
Foundation goes in to looking at these
mott the transportation plans for
individual metropolitan areas we are
really opposed to starting from scratch
and sort of building that's building
something new we try to identify in
those regions the any transportation
models that already exists and you can
work within the system but in part of
what we did in that early those early
stages of research was really trying to
understand and get a sense of what
transportation models were being used
and seemed to have a validity for the
region and we found very early on that
the metropolis 2020 model which was
developed by smart mobility it was
actually a very important starting point
for us and so we developed that we
developed a relationship with smart
mobility as our consultants we liked
their model because it considered
land-use impacts it also considered
things like transit ridership and mode
shifts that that when we were looking at
this in the early stages most a lot of
transportation models really didn't
factor those those issues in but we knew
that was crucial particularly in a
region like Chicago where transit does
play a very important role particularly
in commuter travel and also what was
important for us is smart Mobility's
model looked at time of day pricing
other words it wasn't looking at a flat
price they not looking at a toll that's
one rate they were actually had in their
capacity to think about what happens if
you change the rate over a period of
time there and then what we did is we
added on to that model we actually
underwrote the expansion and adding more
complainers layers and complexity to it
we actually expanded the road pricing
met periods to include seven we're so
not only do we include peak periods we
also include shoulder periods what are
those hours out just next to the peaks
that also are heavily traveled into the
what extent can we use pricing we also
built into the model dynamic pricing in
other words what we're really interested
in doing is ensuring that someone can
get from the free point in Chicago using
some facility the ability to do that in
free flow travel speeds not necessarily
the entire system but the capacity we
were adding what we were trying to do is
say if we're going to build this
capacity and what we want to do is price
it so that you are guaranteed 65 miles
per hour if you're on that road facility
so this is a very different way of
thinking about how you price roads and
how you think about identifying
priorities and we were able to do that
with a smart mobility model there was a
little different trying to think about
how you actually do that that's why we
use experts and consultants to to figure
out how to make that work we also added
income effects the question is if we're
going to grow then your income is going
to grow your choices about
transportation and travel mode will
change that is factored into the model
as well and then we made sure that
everything we were proposing would be
priced there's nothing quote so any user
is going to be paying a price to use
that facility based on the time of day
in the level of congestion so those are
the enhancements that we're adding and
these were the this is a quick summary
of the projects that we identified as
being what we felt were crucial after
consulting with them with a lot of
people I'm not going to go through
individually because sometimes what we
would do is we would when we were first
meeting with the experts and the people
that worked in the area we wanted to
make sure that any controversial project
were ones that we vetted and we didn't
want to actually expose experts to
concerns and the public is especially if
they're not used to being the
a guy so we would take essentially
created a menu of potential projects and
then we examine those projects to
determine whether or not we thought that
improved the mobility on a regional
level as well as in particular segments
and at the end of the day after looking
at that menu in examining the different
effects we ended up with these projects
they're actually a total of eleven these
are the main road pricing ones includes
a what is the crosstown tunnel which has
actually been an idea for a lot of for a
long time in the city of Chicago this is
actually paralleling sisal cicero avenue
an extension to Midway Airport to
provide better access to Midway Airport
also we looked at tunnels parallel
tunnels under Kennedy and eyes now you
might ask why tunnels well in a build-up
urban environment actually expanding
horizontally is not only very expensive
but it it it creates a lot of social
cultural and economic barriers let alone
political barriers and what we found in
looking at infrastructure improvements
around the world is that more and more
cities are going under the looking below
creating tunnels in order to solve the
congestion problems and they're not
actually expanding horizontally so the
question for us became well did it
actually make sense to do that
particularly if your users are paying
for this so tunnels are important the
other thing that which we wanted to
build into this is a regional hot
network high-occupancy toll lanes those
are actually high occupancy vehicle
lanes where you allow single drivers to
use those lanes if they pay a toll and
that would end up and I'll show you in a
minute what that network looks like but
essentially that's what gives you
regional that guarantee of free flow
travel throughout the entire region also
we looked at something that's been on
the plans for a while an outer beltway
and based on our end which is the blue
line here this is new capacity so we've
the idea is to actually recognize that
with all the development outside cook
county that north-south connections were
actually were underrepresented in the
transportation network and we thought
this kind of connectivity would be real
is going it would be very important as
well as these tunnels are really to
provide better north-south connectivity
as well and then we've got the Lake
County corridor which has been on
northbrook Palantine
extension the elgin o'hare extension
which has also been important and of
course the Illiana corridor which is
down here as well so these were the
major projects and in addition to that
well I'm sorry let me this is
essentially if we linked all of these
segments here with the existing toll
network so this is all new capacity
based on when we were looking at the
plans and these things that would be
built then if we linked those two
existing toll roads and existing and
added price lanes to the existing Road
network you would get this regional hot
network which is what's which is what
this represents we also looked and this
is another innovative part of what our
study was doing is we try to figure out
other ways that our arterial system
could be improved and part of that is
using what's called using flyovers or
what we call queue jumpers where a
congested intersections essentially you
build new capacity so you can go over
the congested intersection again this
would be price this is something new and
innovative particularly in the US but
the idea is that in it's actually these
the concept is being implemented in Lee
County Florida where you actually have
this capacity we've got that inside lane
going over the intersection and you're
charged electronically a quarter or
maybe fifty cents depending so you have
that option to do that so we actually
built that into the model as well and we
actually looked at the potential costs
and effects on 54 locations the other
thing we added to this was bus rapid
transit the idea again we have a built
environment very substantial
metropolitan area to what extent does
could we add a bus rapid transit
component to this plan to actually
improve its provide transit access to
the region outside of the existing
network and system and these are the
different these are the different
networks and that we would have actually
created and model alright so what
happens when we sort of take all of
these projects and sort of throw them
into the model and ask her set and price
it the way we want to and what happens
when we're in terms of traffic and the
outcomes that we were looking at one of
the things that we thought was very
interesting is
we actually examined in 20-40 this is a
trend point what is the intensity of the
traffic on each one of these components
of the network that were proposing and
what I think was very important for us
was seeing how important the Crosstown
tunnel would actually be to the entire
network and you can see that in the
intensity of the traffic and again these
are average week this is a vm t / lane
mile on an average weekday other the but
so the tunnels themselves get a fair
amount of hot volume as well as the
midway extension and the elgin o'hare
gets a lot of a lot of traffic as well
but notice also that hot lanes are
important is component of this network
as well yeah pardon this these were
estimated through the modeling the
transfer regional transportation model
of smart mobility so in other words they
factor in income population growth and
also keep in mind that's actually that
this includes the pricing component in
other words even with the tolls on the
roads these are the traffic counts that
are being estimated through the model so
in other words this is not free this is
not people getting on and just being
able to use our the road without
actually having to pay for it so these
are essentially represent paid customers
people that have decided the value of
that road capacity is worth my time and
money to be on that so that's still what
we're generating in terms of traffic
intensity our recommendation is yes in
other words these tools would all be
advertised now this is a modeling
process so yeah yeah it ranged it's
because we've got the multi the multiple
periods so we've got everything it's a
good I think one of the lowest we have
is seventeen cents a mile and the
highest it's about one dollar a mile or
more so it all depends on the level of
traffic because what we're doing is
we're guaranteeing travel time we're
saying if you need to get from point A
to point B we're going to guarantee that
you can do that so that's what it is so
this is just illustrative and in the
report in our appendices we include all
the tables that include all of the toll
rates that were estimated and what they
and what they generate
when we look at the effects oops I'm
sorry when we look at the regional
traffic this is the actual vehicle hours
travel and we've got a number of
different metrics that we went through
and they're all in the study I'm just
pulling out a sampling of this what we
find is that at the baseline this is our
vehicle hours travel currently and if we
don't build any of this capacity this is
where we end up at eight actually I
think up here if we build all the
projects we're actually able to reduce
the rate of growth in this case with
just these 11 projects by the way this
is not with so there are lots of other
capacity would be part of this within
when we factor in real income as you
would expect he would go up we also
looked into different scenarios the
excluding component here is when we
realized that the Eisenhower and Kennedy
tunnels were very expensive the question
we asked is what's the benefit of adding
that compared to the cost so we actually
went through scenarios where we took out
the Kennedy and Eisenhower tunnels to
see what would happen to congestion and
travel delay at that point we also did
that with the queue jumpers and
interestingly enough it doesn't seem to
Eisenhower and Kennedy on a regional
level don't seem to have a huge impact
on reducing the travel delay what we
thought was more interesting in our
modeling was where the clear benefits
the city of Chicago received so we
actually looked at this in terms of the
regional impact on congestion Cook
County and then we actually modeled for
the city of Chicago and what was very
interesting for us is that we're up here
with for the city of Chicago we've got
substantial increase in congestion and
were able to reduce congestion or travel
that measured by vehicle hours traveled
at this point significantly for the city
of Chicago by providing better
north-south connectivity on a regional
level so essentially what we're able to
do is all of that traffic that gets
caught coming into downtown that is
actually trying to get from north to
south ends up being routed under
regional alternatives and that our
interpretation is that's what's
improving the accessibility to the
downtown and the reduction travel to lay
as we see here when we get to the
revenues what this is very something we
found with very interesting the hot
network even though it seemed to have at
least an empirical numbers the lower
level of intensity actually
generates the vast majority of the
revenue that comes from this because
that and we can see that here that in
these types of projects the cross tunnel
and we go actually go into the detail in
the study itself where we look at you
know individual facilities but what this
emphasized to us was the importance of
looking at this infrastructure in terms
of a network effects in the
transportation effect now I think
there's a tendency to look at each of
these projects as if they are isolated
projects when in reality what we're
looking at and what's generating these
revenue numbers is the building out of
all projects so you improve the regional
network capability as part of this and
then the summary in quick summary and
I'm running out of time so I have to so
I'll conclude here with a maybe another
minute or two is this is if you take all
the projected revenue and you look at
our projected costs we actually find
that the user fees in the tolls that are
actually being paid and are actually
paying for these projects so in other
words we're not actually we're with the
user fees in place and tolling and I
think it's important to understand that
this is dynamic tolling because we're
pricing at different levels of the day
based on on peak and off-peak that that
is really what so allowing us to capture
a lot of revenue that revenue allows us
to pay for these projects so this is not
a net revenue loss for the region if
they're built and we think that's
actually crucial to understanding not
only the benefits to what these projects
are but also in terms of understanding
how this could be structured when we go
in our in our study we talked about the
importance of public-private
partnerships and how this actually
provides a really important set of
opportunities for financing and building
these projects so in conclusion we
believe that regional free flow traffic
speeds are achievable if you use
existing technology and you build the
transportation projects and price them
the way we suggest we believe the
Crosstown tunnel as well as the hotline
network and again it's a regional hot
lane network is really crucial to making
the system work and better improve
mobility but also to fund it and also of
course as I already mentioned the users
are going to pay for these new
facilities we're pricing new all new
capacity is being priced in our plan we
are not pricing existing capacity so we
are not actually taking existing roads
and pricing it is all new capacity
that's being priced in this case and we
also recommend a phased approach mainly
thinking given the potential benefits
and costs Eisenhower and Kennedy should
probably be delayed I haven't talked a
lot about the BRT but I'm happy to
address that in QA as well but we also
be believing this is important part of a
conclusion that existing transit network
needs to focus on its core cop cop not
only core competencies but also foot
make sure that that system is brought
back into a state of good repair and is
working efficiently because that has to
be the highest priority in terms of
transits effectiveness on a regional
level all right I've already spent an
extra minute I'm sorry let me see the
podium over to Peters cozy with the vice
president for the Metropolitan Planning
Council and thank you